with us now in the studio is Ben McBean
he's a veteran of the Royal Marines and
also somebody who knows a Prince Harry
from those times and been really good to
see you here in the studio
um how well do you know him
um not that well not as from the outside
of the military only known from like his
time in the military so to speak when
we're in Afghanistan and we flew back
together
now I met him for the first time after
that after my injuries and that side of
how he was in the military and just
after
um yeah absolute Top Class dude and as a
veteran of of the military what do you
make of him his disclosures about the
time there the number of people he
killed how does that sit with you
well yeah I mean that that's his story
and he was there in Afghanistan he
fought he was in a different place to
where I was
um and that that's what he went for that
that's War
um but I suppose it's almost like you're
like eat your meat but then how it's
made if you know what I mean um that's
the reality of War whether you should
have
I'd understand that and the guys who's
with probably understand that in the
military but saying it out loud to
civilians who don't really maybe get it
um obviously doesn't sit well with him
so do you not you don't agree then with
some of these um people that we've
interviewed top military people who've
said it's that's potentially
jeopardizing security of himself and
other people who are still serving yeah
I mean
I don't think it was wise that he said
out loud
um
that's probably what happened but it's
not wise to say it out loud because then
he's already got a tiger on his back
more so than anyone else and it's
probably a bit bigger now and yeah as
potentially cause security risk for
himself his family which is the last
thing he needs
um on top of all the other stuff he's
got anything on his plate anyway
um but he said it now
um and
why I said it I don't know but maybe you
just asked a question you just answered
it
and that's how he kind of keeps his
conscience cleared I don't know but um
it probably wasn't the best idea he said
a lot of things hasn't he Ben
um he's very keen that his side of the
story is out there now you've described
him as a top bloke I think he said
um what do you think of the fact that
these stories he keeps coming out with
them do you think he's wise to do that
you think he's right to tell his side of
the story
um I suppose if yeah if that's I mean
we've heard a lot of what's in the media
and then he's felt like from America he
can say his piece so
fair enough if that's what he wants to
say it's now up to you whether you
believe him or not the thing is it's
kind of you're on their side or the
royal family size so to speak there's no
rule in between so if you say anything
then you get linked to one or the other
but he's decided to say what you said
and it's up to you whether you want to
believe it or not
um but he's probably that's the right
thing to do him in his family so he's
done it and his uh one of the themes
that always comes through is he believes
that the way his now wife then fiance
was treated was appalling um
particularly by the UK media and that
there were strong elements of racism and
misogyny in there do you agree and you
think that that is how she mistreated um
I did
feel like every day it was Harry and
Megan Harry and Megan in a negative way
in the media and even like I wasn't that
interested at first
um I was just happy for them and then it
kind of got on my nerves after a while
because it was constant
but then when they moved away he felt
like from there he could say his peace
and he said his peace and then it was up
to us to see how he felt about it which
we have
um and I I just think then now just you
know if they're racist or this or that
just don't talk to them just go and live
your life um
rather than coming back for a little bit
more and a little bit more because like
today's happened it's not really that
many favors so so you think that he
should just keep his peace now and yeah
I think he said a lot enough overall for
us to work out you know how he feels
about his family
um and he's got enough money in the bank
he's got a beautiful family go and enjoy
the rest of your life and just chill
um you know keep coming back fighting
for whatever then
right now it's not really going down too
well but it's sad because he's such a
good guy as well but you feel sad to be
personally sad yeah just like he is like
not everyone knows him like that I don't
know him that well but I know him enough
to say he's a good guy and a lot of guys
will say exactly the same
um and almost like what he's done in the
military he's kind of been overlooked
because he's done more than most for
this country and people say that we
mustn't Overlook that that he was very
well respected for his time yes that he
said yeah yeah is that is that true is
that an opinion that's universally held
I think the negative thing military-wise
that he's done in my opinion is probably
released saying I killed x amount of
people because you just wouldn't really
say that even if you had
um it's not a rule but you just probably
wouldn't say it
um but apart from that like I mean he
wasn't Apache pilot we used them all the
time we needed them
um in any War you'd need them and he was
up there helping us out big time so
and then these Invictus games all the
money he's ready for charity all the
awareness and stuff and he's a good
decent bloke
um but he's gone down a different route
the minute and that's overshadowing
everything but I don't think the
military now dislike or anything like
that I think that's the thing he's cool
but I think it's fair to say that he
probably shouldn't have mentioned a
couple of bits that he was up to out
there yeah
um
this book hasn't even been published yet
are you going to be reading it no
I do that because I just Harry's a cool
guy and he went to war did his thing and
whatever else and he felt he had to move
for safety's family and everything and I
just think you know what good for him
and if that's the last thing he's gonna
say and live happily ever after then
good for him I don't
need to go into like looking to all the
details of this and that I mean I'll
probably hear it because it will all
come out anyway but I won't be buying
the book and sitting there and really
getting into it um because I'll just
leave him a bit like you know have the
memories that you had from the time yeah
yeah and that's why when I posted a
tweet the day and I just said mate just
shut up man just leave it because like
this is like the good you and at the
minute it's kind of going down that
route and
like we've got four interviews to come
well there we go and yeah I think I
don't say anything more about it all
right
um well really good to have you here in
the studio uh talking to us about uh
your time with him and your thoughts
thank you very much indeed